what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 I'm sitting with Jen Wexler
the director of the Sacrifice game loved
your movie congratulations thanks so
clearly I know about your movie our
audience might not know just yet so can
you give a brief synopsis of your film
yes the Sacrifice game takes place in
1971 around Christmas and uh it's at the
sporting school and a bunch of the girls
have gone home but there's two girls
that have to remain there over break
and then uh uh manson-esque group of
cult Killers comes to the school and
they're up to no good and the girls have
to survive the night you were very ready
for that question and I appreciate it I
thought about it a little bit as you
should so I was reading that you wrote
the first draft of the screenplay in
2013. what is the biggest difference
between that draft and finish film now
oh man there is a big difference
um it would be a major spoiler to reveal
it okay
not to be like tell me now it's it it's
a plot thing okay uh that's the biggest
difference okay I definitely need to
know just to have this information in my
own back pocket after
um I was reading a little bit about how
you really appreciated the bootstrap
approach to filmmaking that glass eye
picks uses so can you maybe give us an
example of how you implement that in
your own filmmaking process now oh for
sure I worked for glass eye picks Larry
fassenden's production company from like
2013 to 2019 I produce like six features
for them my first feature as a director
the ranger was was through glass eye and
um it you just learned to make movies
like with your hands you learn to make
movies with your friends with what you
have available to you and and what's a
really important thing I learned from
Larry is like what matters is what's in
the frame that's what matters that's
what you have to keep in mind as a
director there could be a whole bunch of
things going on what is the frame and
what's the emotional undercurrent
because that is what the frame should be
displaying get even more specific with
that can you maybe isolate a specific
filmmaking technique or tool that like
is Affordable and can be used and made
that way but people Overlook it because
everyone is so focused on like big
budget and resources but you don't
really need those things because these
tools exist you absolutely don't even if
you're making a movie on your iPhone
Embrace that format okay it's an iPhone
movie
um if you can make that part of the
story part of like the re is a found
footage or whatever it is you know just
Embrace that element but then take your
phone and look for the most interesting
frame around you like in this room I
could find 20 interesting things to
point to
um and so you have to like Embrace
what's available to you and use it and
think about theme and like emotion and
metaphor and like like you know you
don't need a ton of money to make
something that's effective All I'm gonna
think about now is the curious little
details in this room I'm just very and
now I want to know what is the what's
the most interesting thing you see in
this room that maybe wouldn't catch
someone's eye but is interesting to you
oh my god well there's a thousand things
I don't know how much you guys can see
in this like I'll take a picture of it
and start it yeah who is that guy I
don't we also have our friend right here
who's floating away there's a fly in
here so yeah you could you could do a
whole story about the fly in this room
that's like bugging us you could just
follow the fly and then we're like out
of focus but you just see hands like
shoving it away so we're not doing any
more interviews it's fantastic best we
are just focusing on our fantastic best
fly short yeah all right so you brought
up the ranger so I'll go there next so I
know that you had said that you had had
the Sacrifice game script but you knew
you weren't ready to make that so you
did the ranger first so what is
something that you accomplish in the
Sacrifice game that you know you can
credit to your experience making the
Ranger so with the ranger it's a movie
that's set in the 80s I like to call it
80s Dreamland like just left of real
life 80s we're a little bit more
colorful a little bit more fairy tale uh
dream like than you know than real life
80s
um but how do you accomplish like an
aesthetic how do you accomplish because
everyone's like oh period pieces are
expensive uh for us the way we did that
on the ranger it's a movie that's mostly
set in the woods and so we have the
woods that's our that's our set and then
we we expressed the period through
costumes so you're only focused on the
costumes and you're only focused on the
props and I took that exact same
approach with the Sacrifice game we had
this incredible boarding school
beautiful location thank you it's called
oka's Abby it's right outside of
Montreal and um so we that was our that
that was our canvas and then how do we
express the the 70s we're doing it
through costumes we're doing through
props and through side dressing and and
yeah music all this stuff it's also
reading that some crew members had
ghostly experiences yeah I love hearing
about those stories so can you share any
with us absolutely so this building was
probably built in 17 or 1800s
um uh it's it's beautiful it reminded me
of like a European art house films uh
and yeah when we were shooting there I
did not have any ghostly experiences
because I there's the Fly By the way
wait oh no it's too far for me now I I
was like really focused on directing so
I was like
ghosts do not get in my head space you
better stay out of my headspace but
other people uh on set
um experience like weird things with
lights our producers were in a room and
there were all these candles that were
set up and they just they were having a
conversation like over here and they all
just knocked down by themselves so
um yeah creepy things happened very open
to and into those kinds of things yeah I
I went far ahead I want to back up a
little because I'm curious if you could
give us a little insight into what it
was like going from first feature to
Second feature because I feel like a lot
of people out there think oh making your
first one is the hardest but sometimes
it could be just as hard if not harder
to get the green light on your second
film after a successful first feature so
maybe can you pinpoint a misconception
about what it is like to get the
go-ahead on your second film yeah for
for me I wanted the Sacrifice game to be
at a a bigger budget than the first film
and that was really the thing that took
a long time
also kovid was in there too so uh nobody
was making movies for quite a while so
it wasn't only
um I felt that I had made a lot of
movies at a at a low budget and and and
learned all about that and I was wanted
to challenge myself and and go up to the
next uh step uh which is why I didn't do
a ton of you know just stuff by myself
during during that time frame I was I
was really focused in that time thinking
about the Sacrifice game writing the
Sacrifice game and like planning for
when the day would come that you know
hopefully we would get to make the movie
um so uh yeah I think I think that's it
yeah so you got there you got to make
the movie and you got to make the movie
with like a killer Ensemble yeah I want
to highlight everyone I'll ask two
questions to get as men at as many of
them as we possibly can first of all the
members of this Ensemble which care
character was the most difficult to cast
where finding the perfect person was
very challenging but then I want the
opposite one where it was like the right
person just magically appeared and it
all worked out I have to say the whole
process was really like weirdly easy in
hindsight easy like in the moment of
course you're like this is hard but like
in hindsight easy
um it really when we had Mina Masood who
so good from Aladdin and and other great
things when he came on and also when
Olivia Scott Welsh came on from Fair
Street and um the TV show Panic
um we were like we had our financing we
were going
um so that was probably the hardest
thing in terms of like getting the movie
going
um which is often how it is like your
green lit when you're cast but then the
process was really great uh Chloe Levine
who's in the Ranger and one of my best
friends I had her in mind when writing
the role of rose and and she came on and
played that role and then we found
um we have Gus Kenworthy who uh plays
Jimmy and he's like an Olympic skier and
uh and just incredible like he's also an
American Horror Story so he's an actor
an athlete he does like everything and
then we through auditions uh worked with
actors from Canada and we found uh it's
an eight person Ensemble piece so we
found
um Madison Baines who plays Samantha uh
Georgia Atkin who plays Clara Laurent
Petra who plays Doug and Derek Johns who
plays Grant and but the process was like
really quick actually like everybody
came on within a couple weeks of us
starting to shoot so yeah I lie now two
questions came into my mind so so first
to highlight I love highlighting the
different uh acting processes out there
can you maybe pinpoint two cast members
in this Ensemble who have complete
different approaches to the work where
it demands something different from you
as their actors director oh interesting
um I'll say that Laurent who plays Doug
is really into improv like he likes to
improvise things which totally works for
the character of Doug and there are some
great lines in the movies that he just
improvised which uh usually I'm a little
bit against improv like I'm like fine
with that I'm like let's do the script
first and then we can do a take where
you like come up with a different line
or whatever but
um uh but some of the stuff that he was
giving was just like it was really
insane it was really in sync with with
the vibe that we were going for
um and um but I have to say everybody uh
I the way I like to work with actors is
I like to have a lot of conversations
with them we kind of like Define the
arcs of the characters we Define the
objectives of like their the characters
overall life what do they want in life
and then and then from there we can go
on a scene by scene basis so uh I I find
that that's like a process of working
for a lot of people with that in mind
which character changed the most after
casting where what that actor brought to
the role took the character in a
different direction than you originally
planned
um I'll I'll say again with Laurent he
really brought that character to life
um I think uh I think he brought I mean
they all for the record they all brought
the character they're uh but but with
Doug I think maybe we had underwritten
him slightly and then Laurent like found
the nuances in the character you can't
have this many main characters and have
them all be memorable unless all of the
actors understand their character know
exactly how to bring them to life on
screen yeah they were all incredible and
what was really really lovely is they
all became like a family on set and
their uh Dynamics and their energies
like fed into each other and they you
know
um Samantha and Clara Madison and
Georgia they became like best friends
while we were shooting which was like
that's what we need that we need that
energy there's a lot of different
relationships dynamics that we're
playing with here a lot of different
people playing off each other and how
does that person feel about that person
how does that one feel about that one
and they everybody was just in sync and
um you know and and created those
relationship Dynamics with each other I
had another Mina question oh I know what
it is was the genie line specifically
written when he was cast in that role it
was
right before he was like it was meant to
be yeah I love that so much he is really
something else in this because I feel
like the large majority like he's done
other things of course but the large
majority of people out there are going
to see Aladdin Take This turn and it is
a delicious opportunity for him yeah and
it was really fun working with Mina and
getting to go to those places and just
being like let's see how evil we can and
he was so down can you maybe give us an
example of a time when he took a really
big swing where whether it's in the
movie or not he just like went for it
well he's incredible because he really
knows how to ride that line and and with
this character he kind of starts off in
a in an evil dark place
and you know and then there's a whole
journey after that so
um so Mina was really great about about
finding that Arc even when you're
starting from a dark place okay so you
brought up starting from a dark place so
I'll go here next the opening Warner can
you maybe pinpoint the most difficult
part of executing a shot or multiple
shots like that yeah it's just a lot of
moving pieces it's a lot of moving
pieces when you have uh you know
you have the camera and you have the
actors and you have the blocking and you
have the special effects and you have
the guy who's in the corner who's gonna
pull the blood at the right time
um and we rehearsed it a lot like we did
a lot of rehearsals of it I feel like by
the end of it everybody uh you know
we're talking about like all night long
this is like all we're doing that night
so but it was it was it was my dream it
was probably the first scene that I I
wrote back in 2013 was this was a scene
so to get to you know to shoot it in
that dream way and also finding that
that house that it takes place at was
literally like two blocks away from the
school where we were shooting so it
wasn't even like we had to change
locations or anything it's just like you
know our home base is at the school and
now we're just gonna okay we're all
meeting two blocks around the corner to
shoot at that at this house which just
looks like it should you know that it
came out of 1971. that is a very well
executed and beautifully framed one or
like in particular just the opening of
it I feel like that that sets the tone
and it's such a memorable image right
right at the beginning thank you very
very well done all right you brought up
uh effects I'll go there next I could
talk about you know like bloody Wild
movie Magic all day long and I know you
had a really great FX team here so can
you maybe pinpoint something that you
did on set or saw them do on set that
made you think like I can't believe that
is what it takes to make it look like
that on screen in oh my gosh well
um we worked with uh we worked we have
the special effects team the blood
brothers so they were responsible for
bringing all the blood they also brought
the snow because we shot in the spring
so they brought the Practical snow also
um and then separately from them we
worked with Adrian Moreau and his team
and they did the Prosthetics so you know
getting to see how those scenes work
together by the way Adrian Moreau like
did the Megan doll and did won an Oscar
for the whale so getting like that was
you know I just on our like um in our
meetings prepping for everything it was
just so fascinating just hearing his
ideas he's the expert I'm like oh tell
me how we can take this idea and make it
like really exciting and really go there
and also
um there's there's a design later on in
the film that I won't get too too deep
into but there's a design later on in
the film that was
um really cool and that was all Adrian
and he rules good tease good teas I like
it all right I'll wind down with maybe
two more questions one one really big
thing that I love to talk about is that
every single film you make you kind of
like find your storytelling boys more
and more and then you're able to apply
that to your next film so can you maybe
tell me like something specific you
discovered about your own voice as a
filmmaker on Sacrifice game that you're
eager to explore more on another feature
film oh interesting
um well I was I will say that I I
started to realize like you you start to
see similarities you know I see
similarities in the ranger in sacrifice
games certainly from a storytelling
perspective I was very aware that I'm
like I like writing scripts about you
know young women dealing with stuff
through the lens of genre like that I
totally knew but then uh in throughout
the process just realizing I the way
that I like you know lenses that I like
to use the like kind of wide angle
lenses close on characters those kinds
of things I'm like oh yeah I use that in
the ranger too but I love it oh it feels
so good I like this kind of like a
little bit comic bookie a little graphic
novel a little like fairy tale esque
taking these worlds and kind of uh just
making them have a slightly fairy tale
kind of quality is something I really
enjoy doing I dig that I can't wait to
see more of it all right I'm gonna end
with a fantastic Fest question here
because I've always wanted to come here
this is my first time coming to the film
festival and the second I walked into
the Alamo I immediately felt that you
know that horror Community love and
support that I love so much and that
I've heard this Festival has like
tenfold compared to any other event out
there so in order to celebrate some of
the other filmmakers here can you
pinpoint something you saw in another
film at Fantastic Fest that made you go
like damn that is incredible and it
inspires me yeah I can because I
literally just saw it before this
interview which is crumb catcher uh
directed by my friend Chris scotchable
and um we worked together at glass eye
picks for years and uh and I'd read the
script and I was I wasn't involved in
the production at all but I'm friends
with them I knew you know I knew about
the production
um and like you know I knew I knew
elements of the production and um but
seeing it I was like damn Chris like you
brought it this is awesome it like wow
it's incredible like seek it out crumb
catcher this is one of the best things
about the festival too it's like a place
filled with people who know each other
yeah but then also for all the newcomers
arriving at the festival for the first
time it's just like it's a community
that welcomes you with open arms like we
have a shared sensibility we love the
same things and we're all meant to be
here together a hundred percent I love
it and your movie is meant to be here
it's something else huge congratulations
on the Sacrifice game I cannot wait to
see what you do next thank you